the Russians about once a week now seem
to launch either a big attack across the
whole of Ukraine or an attack on Kiev
and the attack last night on Kiev was
one of these moments where they used
lots of drones uh shahad 136 drones to
cause as much damage as they could it
doesn't look as if it succeeded very
well because the Shaheed 136 is a
relatively easy to shoot down but as
they can be launched in bulk if only a
few of them get through they do the
damage and these are the sort of debris
the sort of debris that they leave lying
around the issue for the ukrainians is
not so much the shaheeds they can deal
with those but the prospect now that the
Russians are going to get from the
Ukraine is the fatah 110 ballistic
missile and the result faga ballistic
missile these are ballistic missiles
with ranges of 200 and 400 miles now
that would be a big plus for the
Russians as a result of that the
Americans look as if they're about to
cross a threshold they are on the verge
of saying something they've never said
since the beginning of the war they will
give the ukrainians Patriot
anti-aircraft missile systems this is
probably the best in the world it's a
very big system it's very fast it goes
at Mach 4 four times the speed of sound
more than that it can engage targets a
long way away more than 20 miles away
it's ideal for shooting down ballistic
missiles of the sort that the Russians
look as if they're about to receive from
the Iranians in reality of course these
could shoot more or less anything down
but it would be a waste if we use them
on uh cheap drones they would these
almost certainly will be used against
ballistic missiles if the Russians are
going to deploy them and the message
from America clearly is if you're going
to get ballistic missiles from Iran we
will give the ukrainians the things to
shoot them down and we'll get ahead of
the game although they won't appear on
the the battlefield for some time
because they do take a lot of training
nevertheless this is America signaling
to the Russians that we will cross
another threshold if you cross one and
that seems to be What's Happening Now
meanwhile on the ground in Ukraine the
wall goes on and some interesting things
are happening the Russians are moving
more troops it seems out of the kersian
region and they're moving even the uh
the uh the airborne troops the vdv
troops who are their best troops and
they're moving them up to the battles in
Bachman and cremena which is where the
battle is really ferocious the Russians
look as if they've made some lodgement
now into the in into the residential
areas just to the east of bakmut and
they've got around a little bit to the
south of bakmut
um although I don't think they'll
encircle it very easily but they are
making gains there and they really
intend to try to take the town the
ukrainians are fighting back ferociously
the the 93rd mechanized Brigade are
giving a very good account to themselves
but we'll see what happens meanwhile in
cremena the ukrainians look as if they
are going to push the Russians out of
cremena and whatever happens in back
much as we've said many times won't
matter if the Russians lose cremation
because that is the is the main target
and one of the things happening that's
very interesting in the last few days
there have been a number of explosions
around ballito sabotage of the Key m47
Bridge over the m47 highway that Main
Highway that runs all the way to Kirsten
and attacks on Wagner bases Wagner troop
bases around the area of Malita pole the
view of most analysts is that the
ukrainians are engaged here in shaping
the battlefield they're doing some
literpole what they did in cursing a
couple of months ago which is actually
prepare the battlefield by cutting off
Russian Logistics now that Russian
troops are Getting Thinner and thinner
on the ground and the speculation is
that the ukrainians might use their
second and fourth armies the armies
these are Brigade size they call them
armies but they've got a number of
brigades who are in reserve and they
might use those forces to push down from
zapparesia right down to malith Paul on
the coast in other words to open up a
third front in this offensive series of
offensives over the winter now if they
do that they will be relying on the
Colder Weather The Frozen Ground so that
their armor their track vehicles can
really make an impression we don't know
yet if they will do it of course but if
they did that would be another game
changer in their attempt to win back as
much territory as they've lost since the
24th of February it's a possibility I
guess we'll find out when the weather
turns colder and the ground really
freezes